here's how to get calm in three simple
steps
step number one is get outside if you
are stressed out right now the
environment that you're in will keep you
stressed look at all the things around
you right now will keep you stressed so
change your environment ideally get
outside get some fresh air get some
sunlight on your face it will make a
huge difference
step number two is try cyclic cyan
breathing what that means is you're
breathing in as deep as you can through
your nose and then you breathe in a
second time through your nose hold and
then slow exhale do that for 30 seconds
and watch your stress here
and step number three is try to solve
the problem because if all you're doing
is putting Band-Aids on the problem
Band-Aids and Band-Aids and that problem
keeps coming up over and over and over
again you will continue to suffer stress
over and over and over again solve the
problem
belief